thousand go and breath my name is Peter
pot we are looking to have brain DLC
find Pinal pod I'm gonna show all the
endings in this one and you might see
somewhere and you can click you can
click isn't I call you click on the
video and you'll get to choose which
ending you want to see and whatever
order you want are that way so and if
you are on a cell phone or whatever and
you can't click all you gotta do is keep
watching and they should still you know
go along anyway go ahead and click if
you haven't clicked already then I don't
know what's wrong why won't mind cooking
it's because I'm talking all right I'll
be quiet
you
are you still there okay well this has
been fun
good quality time right now so what are
you doing that's awesome okay Jenny
please click now all right how about
that I per office and you click at all
right one two three better click you're
still here I'm just gay all right all
right
dat ass he knows we're coming Braz
that's no bueno
it's also in my attention now that a
taxidermy I like her post a taxidermy is
actually stuffed animal I thought
taxidermist had something that it would
taxes like a I don't know what it's
called an English all this job titles
there follow me a lot different than
Saudi floorboard quick oh [ __ ]
scoreboards gonna get me killed this
floor board comes sniffing around
little secrets all right I'm not good
we're not gonna die hi brother she
always fat solution is not a bad hiding
spot all right
I'm gonna try to get all the endings I
hope this video will be aa beautiful
face
I like I'm Madison like I'm on Lee's
sure you like the hair that much but you
know I'd like us to have a little a lot
some people said that no it's the same
voice of Scott it has to be him when he
was younger it's like really this is
obviously before that all right let's
get out here this is obviously before
that [ __ ] that looks like Slenderman it
really does okay this scares me so much
every time sup mu C mu all right
later foxy um visitor show your babies
alright I know you get one ending gonna
eat you you're just gonna stuff me all
right he has to her that yeah he's
coming [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Madison move Maddy
move
Matty Mauk and look at his nipples
alright now back to me now back to his
nipples uh have you seen my little
darlings No
all right whatever got it something
tells me I'm gonna have shed for my
collection I want to juice ah whatever
there Russ if you're coming why every
day oh you're not supposed to barge in
on people without being invited don't
jump what I don't talk to the puppy like
that and still people who don't respect
my privacy I understand that Shelby I
understand that all right what happens
if we go in here maybe something will
happen
hey what's up what's up what but this is
awkward
move shut always charging mag all right
fighting time [ __ ] no I click on now
are we okay we're okay
Maddy mu is not going down so easy oh
[ __ ]
all right in the nut sack car uh left
why are we going up are you [ __ ]
stupid oh no I'm a victim no way I go
get brown no no no no my doll my pretty
little doll I'm not a doll bro we're
gonna be all mine huh am i hiding am I
seriously hiding are you [ __ ] so bad
don't find me blade so you wanna
I think I like playing - I don't like to
play ha come on honey
I'm gonna take care of you please don't
kill me I have feelings and my body
that's why it oh [ __ ]
oh well I'm sorry I castrated you
alright keep going let's go downstairs
and then what you're not a don't you
dare call me a [ __ ] don't you dare fall
in the stairs don't all right in here
oh shut oh oh the big bag books I made
by boat all right take the shades on
madam oh hey huh ha ha ha boys it's
Scott Shelby killer come on hello to my
little bride here we go come on you
gotta lift it Madison who's the [ __ ]
now [ __ ] oh [ __ ] uh come on Brad
Wow let it do that Maddie said Maddie
said I am disappointed you don't jump um
ah oh no what what why would you do that
ah ah why would you do that why would
you why would you do that alright so
that was one ending the end of a
nightmare
our reporter Madison page fearless
investigation revealed the identity of
the dangerous serial killer
the Stubbs's victim after killing them
Leland White was found dead in Stone
circumstan in the circumstances it's
[ __ ] penis would chop off that the
whole police are currently investigating
the whole police are investigating his
penis
all right I was when I was a [ __ ]
epic ending Jesus Christ that's probably
my favorite so far
all right let's just [ __ ] take the
other endings
all right
the [ __ ] back back again that
[ __ ] ass as my friend
I want him out about it I want to moan
about it I want to mad about it I want
to moan about it I love that [ __ ]
coast she does every time I never get
sick of seeing it okay so this time we
actually have to die which makes me a
little unnerving I just I'm still
thinking about that other episode holy
[ __ ] children floorboards creak oh
quickly all right let's hide in here
actually I think that was a pretty
unusual comes sniffing around my little
secrets
you can't hide here now why not
all right you can do it I'm gonna cut
you up in little pieces oh that's
disgusting and cut up your skin and add
you to my collection well okay
that's not very nice is it don't worry
Madison you're just gonna die don't
worry about it selphie Furman where are
you hiding all right let's just surprise
[ __ ] imma teach you to keep your nose
out of other people's business
surprise [ __ ] anyway nope alright hey
how you done oh yeah how's good that's
good
hey what's up honey I'm gonna take care
of you don't kill me please ah for
Madison
Oh Madison oh [ __ ] Madison no man that's
evil laughter no ah no he's gonna stuff
her ah don't look at them like that
it's so [ __ ] creepy how does that
even work so disgusting I don't want to
think about Madison getting stuff like
that it's disgusting
alright where is Madison page that's the
other ending alright I don't really like
this ending I don't think we bros like
it either but I wanted to do all the
ending so we have to do it we had no
news for several days from our
journalist who is who was investigating
the origami killer the police are
questioning the tag numbers she is
thought to have one in Tequesta
they're questioning the one that she
wanted to question all right let's just
[ __ ] jump into the next one right
right freaking away
don't worry about it look at that ah
it's the only thing are they they don't
show the same thing I love that I'm
never get tired of that I can say me
all right the thing is I don't know
exactly in detail what to this so this
is gonna be a little tricky for me
basically you're supposed to call the
cops
somehow uh Adam floors quick boys lately
Oh metal not go in here let's not go in
here let's not go in here
we cannot die kneazle slipping around my
little secrets bro I'm not a waste
that's a weaselly in the background now
ah in here hey hey Madison messin
getting that today getting night oh hi
to me cause I'll call a my heart your
heart you what or warm I get it ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha no no Madison
[ __ ] it is really difficult to hold all
these button at once I'm actually using
my nipple for one that's right all right
Pat that's 2 up in little pieces
I'm gonna cut up your skin and add you
to my collection
your main you know that all right all
right all right what what is that what
is this no no no we don't have time for
this there's supposed to be a phone here
call the cops call the cops don't come
here doug-man no come here don't come
out no come here
yeah
let's break now man that you would just
do it all right with your breath now
what oh [ __ ] it's gonna come in here Oh
God
better go underneath the bed huh oh shut
all right how's the gun left I'm sorry
right left down with the left oh [ __ ]
well Gabba Gabba Gabba do it what oh
nice going mad EMU go left
that was the right I'm sorry I keep
getting out don't call me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] don't fall in the stairs
please
uh no no why go here alright let's just
escape oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
hey how's God and I like your collection
yeah I don't count it whoa shut [ __ ]
keep runnin Madison she is [ __ ] leap
that dodging stuff well now
all right oh [ __ ] we can't escape no no
I missed it the school otherwise no idea
going back here bro all right the garage
the garage door yes
crawl under d'Artagnan bro forget you
don't need no helmet throw the knife
resumption oh go go yes I'm the type of
shadow senator does not not that don't
kill me please no oh no Mary Jo I'm beg
oh [ __ ] he's not that good I guess like
then I get a different ending or did I
get the right ending I'm so confused
right now all right here we go I don't
know I guess I have to die or some [ __ ]
so you've seen my bathtub haven't you
know where you'll be sleeping tonight oh
no oh no I'm supposed to die so I can't
really do that much I guess I know
you're not supposed to barge in on
people relining I didn't don't joke I am
I'm sorry I can still
oh [ __ ] Erica I asked again I like your
collection
I prefer Pokemon cards but oh wow you
can really die in a lot of ways and oh
no Maddie sad open immediately how the
cops are here
[ __ ] yeah don't move right shoot hands
up heads up I said
aah with Madison died I don't like this
ending Ava well at least she didn't
become my god what happened here well
people die I guess and it stuffed them
and that was disgusting and I'm still
talking sacrifice in the name of their
Rega
the police have found fearless
journalist Madison page dead in the home
stereo girl she was about to reveal the
truth concerning the mysterious
disappearance of
several women men she herself was
savagely murder the police have arrested
a psychopath that responsible for her
murder and many other murders for that
matter that's a little sad ending I
don't ever like that one either
I want Madison to live goddamn it
alright which one did we have left now
alright let's go he's watching the TV
I'm sneaking up upstairs I don't know
why was he watching that's a real Timmy
that's Lou all right he can't hear me
when of the [ __ ] cops arrived [ __ ]
wrestling a shake
he doesn't even care that someone was in
his house well
it would be nice if the cops came you
know
what is she holding now I don't want to
hide behind your boobs what else do we
got
that's a pretty terrible attack
there's a the cops oh no keep your nose
ah finally thank God
whoa
yes look after your skin I'll be back
for her toys we'll see about that
ha don't move right shoot
hands up heads up I said alright that
was that ending I guess jaysis Christ
Madison right ah she's okay good alright
I'm glad she lives at least a now so
that was that makes me real sad just
like Madison oh don't cry Madison I know
the heavy rain series is over but there
will be a new game in 2013
Madison dunk ah poor Madison alright so
I will never ever ever ever ever ever
ever step inside a taxidermist house and
in a while okay there it is the end of
anguish I don't know how it what the
hell that means our general is Matt's
big restore life to investigate the
dangerous killer would stop victims
after killing them she was trapped in
The Killers house as he returned home
after she had broken in search of
evidence fortunate for her she alerted
the police and owes her life to their
timely intervention interpret what